you leverage your imagination you
leverage the insane ability to picture
the events that are going on arcane is
one of the most stunning animated shows
out there and we have the amazingly
talented creative team to thank for not
settling for less than perfect casting
number one you may have known her as a
singer or possibly you got to know her
thanks to hawkeye hayley steinfeld is
used to the mic and to acting so she
didn't find it too difficult to really
get into the voice acting zone dimming
the lights in the booth helped set the
tone it was a challenge not being able
to physically be in the character but
there's something freeing to her about
letting the emotion take over in the
intimacy of the booth ella purnell and
haley never actually met in person at
least while working on this project we
we did meet one time when we were 11 at
a magazine thing because kovid and other
reasons everything had to be done remote
but they did get to meet at the premiere
the most part we were just like
co-reading against each other haley did
a lot of research going on reddit forums
taking in everybody's opinions and then
interpreting them filtering them only
then did she give her own flair to it
number two ella purnell on the other
hand refused to consult the internet out
of sheer intimidation you may know her
from yellowjackets star trek prodigy
army of the dead or maybe recognize her
as young maleficent from the live-action
film well
look who it is
the boy savior i've been waiting for a
role like this for a really long time it
was daunting to try and cast for this
show because of six years worth of
expectations it was bananas i mean we
literally just i think it went through
like three or four different casting
directors casting influenced not only
the design of the characters but also
their attitudes and character traits we
looked for the jinx actress i think for
roughly three years they went through
three or four different casting
directors and were ready to give up for
a while we were like
can we find someone who can do this they
needed an actor who could do extremes
very well the intimate and quiet moments
and the loud moments that jinx is known
for very bombastic ladies you know that
we know from the game this was my first
ever voice over audition uh so i didn't
really know what i was doing she was
doing an accent i just do the accent and
then they choose the rest and to really
feel the physicality of the character in
the booth she was like jumping around
like punching myself in the stomach like
climbing the walls it's crazy in there
number three next up you probably
recognize her best as cho chang from
harry potter katie lung tried to ignore
how popular her character was because it
would be overwhelming to have in her
head when she's just looking for the
humanity in the character beyond her
like really kind of
beyond her skills as a marksman she's
she's like so much more than that katie
has a different british accent than her
character and so a lot of the time she's
just focusing on that an rp accent
because she is highly educated she comes
from wealth for caitlyn i feel like
she's always kind of she's holding back
a lot of the time she doesn't find that
hard to play because she kind of does
that anyway number four mia sinclair
jeanness played matilda for the us
broadway tour and of course you know she
voiced nancy on the disney junior show
fancy nancy no worries there powder took
care of the evidence she got the job at
10. they were gonna make a 11 12 year
old girl cry let's see how that goes it
can be tough to get raw emotional
performances from such young actors in
the voice studio she left me
she is not my sister anymore that wasn't
a problem with mia i remember all of us
in the booth just like
being shocked by how good she is she had
them in tears mia has a very close
connection with her brother and uses
that to relate to her character next
thing i knew it was all just
coming to the surface number five mick
wingert is known for his impression of
jack black and kung fu panda legends of
awesomeness and also tony stark in what
if the audition for heimerdinger came
out of the blue for the prolific voice
actor he'd never played the game i love
a good conundrum before he did his
audition they said on the sides we're
not looking for a voice match if they
were they would have just gotten david
to play heimerdinger if it is within my
knowledge i will share that with you
they almost didn't have hymer in the
show because they were worried he'd be
too cartoony so they needed to cast
somebody who could bring a lot of heart
to the character people love a grand
reveal number six kevin alejandro played
detective daniel espinoza in lucifer i
didn't know a whole i'm gonna be honest
i know a whole lot about the world until
i talk to my 13 year old son his son
reassured him this would be the biggest
thing he ever does in his whole life so
kevin figured he should just maybe do
some research jimmer is rampant in the
undercity attacks at the hex gates and
in the academy square kevin feels
honesty rings true in the character when
you put a touch of yourself in for him
that touch was genuine kindness
number seven maybe you remember him from
game of thrones daenerys targaryen's
cruel brother
well what was really nice is that the
victor everyone knows is not the victor
we start off with by the end of the
journey he will be far more recognizable
so the actor found it fun to start
backwards he was encouraged to be brave
and not try to fit it into anything and
to break out a little bit number 8. jb
blanc played braum in the league of
legends video game you've got a good
heart don't ever lose it no matter how
the world tries to break you he's a
father to a 16 year old she's not a
criminal but you know she can come close
sometimes so he took some inspiration
from his own experiences both his
characters are guys with heart so the
casting made sense number nine prolific
voice actor jason spiezak voiced the
joker in teen titans go i was actually
delighted that i was playing somebody
who isn't in the lord he found it
exciting because he had more artistic
freedom with the character and there was
a certain element of mystery to him that
fans wouldn't have any expectations for
there's this wonder that you aren't sure
what you're going to get from the
character the phenomenal script is what
makes these things easy to imagine i
have the power now number 10. improv is
a voice actor's best friend hammer
forging is such a delicate art well so
is improv so the creative heads in the
room were all for improvising in the
booth if i wanted to tweak some phrasing
they
the creatives were like yes go for it
which is always awesome to hear you get
the take you need just in case and then
you play around a little it's a very
collaborative process we must have done
so many different texts yeah but i i
said i already called it you can't do
i called dibs number eleven let's dive
into the minds of arcane's co-creators
the one thing the writer and director
duo alex yi and christian link pushed
for was authentic performances they
wanted the actors to really dig deep and
find what was real and grounded and a
lot of them found that by bringing just
a little bit of themselves to the roles
sometimes the director came into the
room and played the scenes with the
actors since they didn't record together
they would do take after take with
slight variations but none of it felt
wasted because it all felt like acting
process number 12 these guys need no
introduction their music is radioactive
imagine dragons are all league of
legends players they were approached
very early in the process with the
concept art alone they love having
themselves animated into the show
they're not a group who collaborate
often but working with jid on the song
enemy for arcane was awesome just an
incredible artist i have a lot of
respect from he's also just a really
thoughtful sweet good human being arcane
truly is packed with a stellar cast what
we're still most impressed by is mia's
raw performance it's inspirational so
are you team vi or team jinx let us know
in the comments and thanks for hanging
out with us here at the things